[Music]
hey vogue it's kim we're here in my home
i've like filled it up with some amazing
art and all my favorite things i can't
wait to show you kim kardashian is
taking fans inside her luxurious
calabasas home and sharing her most
prized possessions in the latest
installment of vogue's objects of
affection so the first object of my
affection is my daughter north's
paintings and drawings she's a really
really good artist and she loves to
paint she does like little paintings for
me like this wolf she did do one of our
bearded dragon and in true
mother-daughter fashion kim also has the
crafty jean too she loves a good
scrapbooking sesh each kid
has their own book pictures from all
their baby showers to how their birth
announcement was i have all of their
little hospital
details i've written out you know mom
and dad's history
her first vogue shoot
everyone that visited her
there's sonograms
what i ate the whole pregnancy
i really wanted to archive these
memories and it's just it's really
really cute another spot in the house
for the kids to make memories the
backyard the
basketball court especially is where the
kids love to be you know i didn't want
your typical basketball court i don't
know if you can see the material of the
ground but it's like spongy and i just
wanted it really neutral not only is it
a hot spot for the little ones but the
whole kardashian family when it's
summertime in the pool's right here and
the gym connected to the basketball
court music blasting and kids are in the
pool and me and my sisters are like
lunging up and down the basketball court
there's nothing
more fun than a good workout day at my
house and check out this meadow where
the reality star and her fam farm get
their green thumbs on if you go up there
you'll see a huge vegetable garden so
many trees and so we grow our own fruits
and vegetables and we pick them and eat
them just from there of course we know
kim loves her cars she even keeps her
collection in a gray palette to match
the color scheme of her house my house
is gray and i wanted him to kind of
match the house i put out my three faves
my lamborghini uris and my rolls-royce
is great also it's a ghost
it has like the cutest little crystal
lady and then my favorite baby ever ever
ever is the maybach sedan
i love everything about it if i were to
pick one
that's my baby right there the
kardashian star has never been shy about
sharing her unique home with fans on
social media like her lush bathroom
balcony that's our patio out there
our whole ceiling is a light box and
check out her restaurant grade
refrigerator we keep all of our fresh
organic produce and if the house looks
familiar it's because it is it's the
same home she once shared with her now
estranged husband kanye west who
recently bought a separate home on the
same street but he recently returned to
his old digs to drop off an extravagant
floral display for kim one of his many
attempts to win her back
[Music]
meanwhile kim's new beau pete davidson
is supporting her through this
transition a source tells e.t that the
couple has gotten even closer in the
last few weeks and that this is not just
a fling it's way deeper than that